[Music]
in good ACT gone wrong news like that
happens apart all the time like what I
don't know he does something good but
then he [ __ ] it up and then I end up
getting pissed and he's like but my
intentions were good I'm like dad but
you [ __ ] it all up
no you just read it wrong I think this
was submitted by arugula oh I eat your
ass that's really [ __ ] bitter no it
looks like this yeah it's like it looks
like asparagus really I don't know she
likes it it was really clean that's
green tastes the same to me I agree like
kale arugula cuz you girl
kale taste bitter I think you know
really things they just salt taste
Garrigus I don't like asparagus and I
love every other pile of asparagus they
all just taste green to me
have y'all had broccolini though it's
broccoli but it's long baby broccoli
it's Italian this is about to take a
turn a man was murdered after stopping
to help a stranded motorist who turned
out to be a hitman hired to kill him
that's why you don't stop from four
people and change at any point of those
movies taken no the movies were like
crazy should always happen final
destination yeah I've never even seen
those but that's not like a final
destination moment where it's like that
was not possible because you've never
seen it that is completely wrong but I
admire your confidence while you said it
final destination but that's the final
destination killer final destination is
like visit here and since it's in my
cards that I need to die this'll fog a
freak accident night dies yeah
not afraid guys like a mousetrap you
played the game mouse trap like a bunch
of [ __ ] happening at wants to kill the
person that's a white people game yeah
I've never played ever played a mouse
trap it's a thousand dollar game that we
all has kids
I remember the commercials
white kids playing you know from the
headlines you know I feel I should feel
sorry but I can't help but to feel that
this is so badass because like assassin
did his job so well I know this is like
the first hitman story that was
successful that's so sad what if it was
like insurance money this was really sad
cuz this dude did not deserve it oh [ __ ]
who hired the hit man I will tell you oh
okay
all right so the victims name is Carlos
he was a 16 year old
army vet whose car was found several
miles away
Torche there was also this truck that
was stuck in the mud nearby so it kind
of seemed like whoa like he was trying
to help someone because that car wasn't
ended up being stolen they were thinking
that whoever had the stolen car was
getting help from Carlos and then all of
a sudden they just went crazy and then
just shot this dude and then torched his
car and then took off but no it turned
out that six months before he died
Carlos was in this road rage case where
he honked at the car in front of him
because it was a green light the car in
front of him didn't move and then the
person inside of that car his name is
Kelsey drove around and pulled out a gun
on Carlos and then Carlos called the
police and reported it and so they were
gonna go to court for that but this dude
Kelsey he already had some [ __ ] on his
record cuz he was already a felon he was
charged with aggravated assault and
unlawful possession of a firearm by a
felon cuz Carlos is able to write down
the license plate and that's how he was
able to report everything and then they
were gonna go to court but then in order
to avoid going back to prison that's
when this dude healthy hired one of his
felon friends who was known as a killer
to kill this sixty year old man
or that road rage case [ __ ] up yeah
with the name like hell so you no wonder
he's a [ __ ] so this is what I'm
picturing the hit man had his car like
he knew like Carlos's route so you had
his car like parked and [ __ ] and it with
Carlos drove by he was like help me no
but how did he know Carlos is a nice guy
so listen Kelsey's 21 year old pregnant
girlfriend was staking out this whole
thing so and by the way Kelsey's 28
because you guys were wondering and then
the killer is 24 and the name's Benjamin
so the girlfriend and Benjamin they were
like staking out and like trying to make
sure like what's his route usually and
so that damn they followed him for a
while and then finally when it was day
that Benjamin was gonna kill him then he
didn't end up being at the place that
they thought he was gonna be so then
when Benjamin did a u-turn his truck got
stuck in the mud and then that's when
Carlos shows up to help but like you
just say it was just not listening
[ __ ] crazy
the victim came to him yeah that's like
going hunting and then they come to you
exactly and then as he was helping with
the truck that's when he shot him behind
the head and it took a whole year to
figure this out too like for the
detectives because it was so
specifically done and planned yeah but
you got lucky he's not even like a pro
because what he's not a pro yeah when
you said like pregnant wife I thought he
was gonna use her as bait meat and then
the baby was gonna be an accessory to
murder and [ __ ] but like that was gonna
I was gonna be like Carlos like playing
on his heartstrings like oh no pregnant
lady I got a help you know that would
have been really drove right into the
mousetrap oh you look so happy too man
yeah and then these are the people
involved so this was the dude in the
road rage case this is his pregnant
girlfriend and this is the killer
she's an accomplice now yes which means
the baby can be tried as an adult right
in America so they should be she's so
pretty [ __ ] yeah so this they're saying
that they're trying to get the death
penalty for them but what about the baby
though I don't know the baby's gonna be
locked up two babies in the system I
don't even know if the baby's born yet
I've seen a women's jail close to where
we go shoot at and there's like a
playground like within the [ __ ]
barbwire [ __ ] tall ass fences it's
crazy it's like the weirdest thing like
when you drive by it's all like hi
[ __ ] security and it's like these
colourful little that's how I feel when
I see McDonald's plate place it's always
like oh damn [ __ ] germs yeah it's
like a kid though like abandon the
amusement park like nobody wants to use
it [ __ ] anymore that's true it's like
hasn't been cleaned since the 80s yeah
that's a really [ __ ] up story though I
know I keep really I was thinking this
guy like you know did something terrible
to a family member but really he got
pissed I would have done the same thing
I would have hog we're at a green light
go then they point a gun at me okay I'm
gonna get a license plate like you just
pointed a gun at me for honking at you
you know anybody would do that that's
why I don't talk as much as I should
oh my god because you people don't know
like what people are capable of and
there are so many cases especially in
the summer when people just walk out of
their car and start shooting because
like people are pissed and [ __ ] yeah
it's hot no you know what it's usually
the summer yeah actually last summer I
was in my car
and I had my window rolled down I don't
remember who was in the car with me but
we were driving and there was this guy
who was just kind of like clearly pissed
about something and he walked into the
street at the stoplight and like slammed
on a guy's car like he hit the back of
the trunk and the guy got out started
getting his face and the guy that hit
his car just pulled out a knife and it
became like a knife fight in front of me
they pulled the other guy pulled out a
knife and then they were just kind of
like nice shouting when the next em down
the brea like some some more random like
very common Highland I don't know but
yeah there's a musical
it's because I wasn't so light hard in
my mind I thought I saw two guys like
bleeding all over the add a soundtrack
to this deadly thankfully from what I
remember it didn't I mean I don't think
either of them drew blood it was just
kind of like are we doing this and then
they got scared both them got scared and
they're just like get the [ __ ] out
because it became a human moment that's
what's so interesting about traffic
I get so [ __ ] mad because I see this
metal box that just pissed me off I
don't see a person with eyes and a face
right I think by law all cars should
have eyes and mouths and like Thomas the
Tank Engine like movies because then I
couldn't really get pissed you know I'm
saying oh my god and then it could show
your mood right then it wasn't like
you're like Elon Musk happen yeah and
then you look at like all this [ __ ]
didn't get sleep all right buddy all
right you know what I mean this really
would solve road rage cuz I don't think
I can get pissed at that and it's gotta
be the same age cuz then if it's like
old then you kind of give it respect
like okay I'll be pissed right I'll be
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with this
[ __ ] and I Drive up and I'm like sorry
grandma I know yeah you're like are you
going 20 into 50 it's like a little old
lady and I'm like no you get home alive
I've never respected you more than I do
at this very moment because I invented
something that is that would save the
people right it's amazing because when I
was a kid too I was always like why
don't they just like have little
computers where you can like communicate
and then it says like I'm sorry for
cutting you off that were just like
quick responses not just sticking my
hand out like hey I'm sorry I did
there's not a single car either that
would not look dope ER with eyes in the
mouth what I used to think of too and I
was like really little and my parents
would get road rage and stuff I'm like
man why can't they have this thing where
you can like walkie talkie each other's
cars and then you can communicate that
way truckers have yeah
like do you know how much more
shit-talking what exists like IG
comments dude but like in real life now
they're protected in their car or guy we
just go in with nice nice tits and then
he'd speed off like you can get real
yeah if you like set things that they
could say like this is everything like
buttons like prompts or it's like sorry
about that or like thanks for letting me
in hit the button
anyone invading my my little zone you
know I'm saying like if somebody could
be like hey let's titties or something
into my wife I'd be like yo what the
[ __ ] who is this guy and then I'll chase
him down and kill him you know yeah
right all right that that's the opposite
of what we want to have happen right I
just want humanity I want the faces I
like the idea of it reacting to our
expressions like what we feel it's like
a mood ring but for your car or we could
all have machine guns mounted on our car
and then pointing at other cars I'm
gonna so then what it does is now
everyone is nice if I'm on PMS still
that shit's going off but you have guns
pointed at you - oh all the cars have
guns pointed each other's what if it's
the opposite and instead of the guns
they're all covered in fur like in dumb
and dumber and it's Hartig a stuffed
animal so just like it's like a duck on
the freeways will abused dogs too much
for that I'm sorry we always when you
get really mad your stuffed animals like
the first thing as a kid that you would
just start slamming around the rooms
butcher stuffed animals and post the
videos on YouTube with guns then I think
we already solved it babe we did yeah
we're gonna go to the faces we're going
with one with my idea power you just got
to accept it okay I think we need to
enquire with Elon Musk I think you can
make this happen
I like furry cars with guns why do they
gotta have guns - gotta kill people
[Music]
[Music]